hey youtubers is charlie so a bunch of
Walking Dead stuff happening tonight
this is going to be a video for the
preview stuff they did for season 6 and
then I'm going to do a video for episode
12 fear the walking dead that'll be
completely separate video but fear the
walking dead totally awesome I think
it's going to be really fun show and
there's only six episodes of it in real
quick reminder i'm doing a new round of
the giveaway it's a twenty-dollar amazon
gift card all you have to do to enter is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on
this video so here we go Walking Dead
Season 6 preview they showed a really
short clip and previewed a couple of the
new characters are bringing in from the
comics there are three really big
characters there's Ethan Embry he's
going to be an amalgam of a bunch of
characters they didn't say anything more
about it I think it'd be spoilery to
explain which characters so we'll have
to wait till we see some footage of him
before we guess which comic book
characters he's based on but the other
two are actually pretty easy there's
heat and dr. Denise Denise Cloyd they're
both Alexandria saves own characters
from the comics they're going to be on
the show now they'll be pretty close to
their comic book characters so if you
have read the comics just using a
spoiler tag when you talk about what
happens to them you have to remember
that the comics are way further ahead
than what they're doing on the show
right now so even though they change a
lot of things from the comics they're
starting to do more comic book scenes
they haven't really alluded to it but I
do think that we'll see hilltop some
time this season not expecting negan
that's way further off of the distance I
know everybody just always asked about
nique and anytime there's a new season
of walking dead they did show a little
Abraham and Sasha clip I'll play it
right now
you're good yeah I'm trying
listen if you're still looking to go
buck wild with the breath impaired you
already asked the question and I already
answered it
if you were so worried why the hell did
you get into the car with me
listen doing something as big as this
that's living
here it is so as you can see that's
that's nothing it's just Abraham
wondering if Sasha's gonna wig out on
him like you okay you gonna flip out on
me it seems like Sasha slowly coming
back from the brink and and Rick is the
one that's going crazier and crazier
Early's as people are gonna wonder it
they just they play with your head a
little bit whenever they show trailers
whenever they drop the comic con trailer
last month they were just they were
hyping up Rick versus Morgan and that's
not necessarily going to be the
narrative of the season but they will
address that issue because where they
are right now it's like the reverse of
the last time that Rick and Morgan were
together Rick was completely together
Morgan was the crazy one now Rick looks
like the crazy one and Morgan's got his
[ __ ] together next big thing they said
that the season premiere is going to be
the biggest episode that they've ever
done ever the scope of each episode has
gotten bigger which I think they kind of
have to do at this point it's the most
profitable show on TV if they're going
to keep it popular they're gonna keep
having to try and top themselves but it
is really hard to top blowing the [ __ ]
out of terminus I think right now my
favorite premiere is still season 5
episode 1 the very first episode season
1 episode 1 was a lot of fun just
because it was brand new like we hadn't
seen the walking dead on TV before but
just just looking at the rest of the TV
show i would say season 5 episode 1
probably the most fun one for me for
those that are wondering there isn't
going to be any direct crossover between
the main show in the spin-off this first
season there's only six episodes of the
spin-off show they're just they're
teasing [ __ ] going crazy in la devolved
into apocalypse so maybe like in the
second season the timeline will catch up
with the main show but it won't happen
right away but remember spin-off show
happening in Los Angeles main show in
Washington DC right now so you guys can
let me know like based on some of the
new stuff that you've heard about season
six what are you looking forward to most
like do you really want to see hilltop
more stuff from the comics I think we
all really want to see Morgan go up
against Rick at least a little bit even
if they end up on the same team by the
end there is a real battle of
philosophies that they're teasing but
Lennie James did say that he has been
practicing hardcore with that bow staff
so we're gonna see way more Morgan Jedi
action and in this season I'm getting to
learn a particular skill that
stuff and I'm slightly obsessed with it
I spend evenings in my apartment on my
own playing music and just swinging a
long stick so what's gonna happen next
is I'm going to post my fear the walking
dead episode 1 video and I'm just remind
everyone about the giveaway whenever I
post that show it should be up in a
couple hours and i will do a Q&A for
both of these things tomorrow just like
i would normally do Game of Thrones
after that just because I'll like the
Stephen Amell SummerSlam Walking Dead
stuff going on today I just didn't have
time to do a regular Game of Thrones
bonus video while you wait for all that
stuff to post you can click here for my
fear the walking dead episode 1 video
I'll add the annotation as soon as I
post it int you can click here for The
Walking Dead Season 6 full trailer thank
you so much for watching everybody let's
high five I'll see you guys tonight